well welcome everybody today is a Friday
show sort of I know it's Wednesday but
it's our last show for the week because
of the upcoming Thanksgiving holiday and
sort of a Friday show in format we'll be
taking a few live calls later but not
quite as many as we normally would on
Friday I do have a bunch of stories I
want to talk about and I want to start
with what we all knew was only going to
be a matter of time right-wing media is
now blaming the victims of the Club Q
shooting in Colorado you know I didn't
cover this shooting already
and I got a couple emails asking why and
I'm going to delve into it more next
week actually but when these shootings
happen first of all I will often wait a
couple of days because I want to get the
information right and these shootings
are so common I mean just look at
gunviolencearchive.org oftentimes
there's not that much more to say now
this one had a particularly nefarious
element to it in that it does appear
that the target was chosen because of
anti-lgbt sentiment and because of now
the use of the term groomer by the right
which is basically applied uh as a a
typically sexually predatory or
otherwise predatory term to everything
from drag shows to just a gay couple
that wants to adopt a kid they are now
using that framing to do some victim
blaming and I'm going to play a couple
of examples for you here is one from
Tucker Carlson where his guest Jamie
Mitchell who is the founder of an
organization called gays against
groomers
helps Tucker Carlson say listen this is
going to continue until we end gender
affirming care listen to these
disgusting people
didn't have to be said but what is
anti-lgbtq that these people need to
understand and what is putting our
community in great danger is uh you know
claiming that all of us support this and
just associating all of us with this
um you know saying that groomer is an
anti-lgbtq slur that is doing
irreparable damage to us uh as a whole
and is putting a really large Target on
our backs and unfortunately you know the
tragedy that happened in Colorado
Springs the other night uh you know it
was expected and predictable
um we all within gays against rumors saw
this coming from a mile away and sadly I
don't think it's going to stop until we
uh end this evil agenda that is
attacking children now by evil agenda
she's referring to gender affirming care
which we've already talked about in
detail it is not some wild heretical
thing it is actually something based in
years and years now of study and they
want to frame it as basically pervert
doing things to your kids so so saying
listen this is going to keep happening
until we stop gender affirming care
they're not even hiding it at this point
there's no consequences for them at
least not thus far so why would they
stop they wouldn't here is another
example this is Matt Walsh Matt Walsh
we've talked about him before he's
become very known among right-wing
cultural circles and Social Circles as
the guy who really hammers on this
scourge of uh transgender gender
affirming care Etc
here he is doing another version of look
what you made me do to you that's a
classic from abusers why do you keep
making me punch you in the face family
friendly drag shows quote-unquote have
two purposes
one from the drag queens perspective is
to satisfy their fetish for
cross-dressing in front of children
the other on a more macro level is to
indoctrinate children into queer Theory
to put it simply
the point of drag queen Story Hour and
the child the the supposed
family-friendly drag shows is to turn
your children queer that is the goal
and whenever you say that by the way
consider how insane that is consider how
absurd that is given the reality of what
we know about sexual orientation turn
your children queer this is It's it
seemed this guy was in diapers when that
talking point was already being debunked
just said right there's me clip on me
any matters hello everybody on Twitter
um
the people who invented it stated
explicitly that that is the point to
help children live clearly that's their
quote
and the thing about the left is that
what they believe and what they do
all of it is so horrifying so perverse
so degraded that if you just quote them
then you somehow sound like the crazy
one if you quote what they are saying it
makes it sounds crazy just to say it out
loud because it's so horrifying
yet it's true
and this is the reason the left cares so
much about this and they defend it so
vigorously because according to the last
think about this
according to the left
the drag queen child combination has
become dangerous they say it's a
lightning rod for violent backlash
right that's what they said and it's
greatly exaggerated of course mostly
it's invented out of whole cloth
actually but
but even by their version of events
if it's causing this much chaos and
violence
why do you insist on continuing to do it
right if according to you it's like
putting people's lives at risk
if if the effort to have men
cross-dressed in front of children is
putting people's lives at risk why are
you still doing it is it that important
to you
now as always they try to flip the
burden around on us
they demand that we explained why we
object to children being exposed to drag
queens but of course it's not about
objection it's about violence and this
is of course outrageous right listen if
the thing you're doing is angering
lunatic so much that they shoot at you
just stop doing the thing isn't that
exactly the type of speech they say
shouldn't be curtailed by threats of
violence it doesn't make any sense and
these folks this one from day one had a
tinge to it where we knew they were
going to blame the victims if you just
stop doing this crazy stuff then people
wouldn't go and start shooting you up
blame the victims blame that they often
do it with rape and they're doing it
here one of our sponsors is monk pack
making amazing granola bars and the nut
and Seed bars that are chewy Sweet and
delicious but I especially love them
because each bar has only one gram of
sugar two to three net carbs and about
150 calories perfect if you do keto or
low carb or like me you're just trying
to stay conscious about sugar intake you
get the satisfying crunchy salty sweet
experience you were looking for without
the sugar monk pack comes in flavors
like sea salt dark chocolate caramel sea
salt they launched two new flavors which
are great peanut butter cocoa chip and
dark chocolate cocoa I keep monk pack
granola bars and nut and Seed bars in
the pantry at all times there great on
the go for a quick snack while you're
working if you don't love them as much
as I and our team do monk pack will
refund all of your money or exchange the
product whichever you prefer go to
monkpak.com and you'll get 20 off your
first order with the code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below